the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so I'd like to begin the second
lecture by reminding you what you we did
last time so last time last time we
define the derivative as a slope of a
tangent line so that was our geometric
point of view and we also did a couple
of computations we worked out that the
derivative of 1 over X was minus 1 over
x squared and we also computed the
derivative of X to the nth power for N
equals 1 2 etc and that turned out to be
X sorry NX to the N minus 1 so that's
what we did last time
and today I want to finish up with other
points of view on what a derivative is
so this is extremely important it's
almost the most important thing I'll be
saying in the class but you'll have to
think about it again when you start over
and start using calculus in the real
world so again we're talking about what
is a derivative and this is just a
continuation of last time so as I said
last time we talked about geometric
interpretations and today what we're
going to talk about is rate of change as
an interpretation of the derivative so
remember we drew graphs of functions y
equals f of X and we kept track of the
change in X and here the change in Y
let's say and then from this new point
of view a rate of change keeping track
of the rate of change of X and the rate
of change of Y it's the relative rate of
change we're interested in and that's
Delta Y over Delta X and that has
another interpretation this is the
average change usually we would think of
that if X were measuring time and so the
average and that's when this becomes a
rate and the average is over the time
interval Delta X and then the limiting
value is denoted dy/dx and that is the
so this one is the average rate of
change and this one is the instantaneous
rate
okay so that's the point of view that
I'd like to discuss now give you just a
couple of examples so let's see well
first of all so maybe some examples from
physics here so Q is usually the name
for for a charge and then DQ DT is
what's known as current so that's one
physical example a second example which
is probably the most tangible one is we
could denote the letter s by distance
and then the rate of change is what we
call speed so those are the two typical
examples and and I just I want to
illustrate the second example in a
little bit more detail because I think
it's important to have some visceral
sense of of this notion of instantaneous
speed and I get to use the example of
this very building to do that probably
you know or maybe you don't that on
Halloween there's an event that takes
place in this building or really from
the top of this building which is called
the pumpkin drop so so let's illustrate
this idea of rate of change with the
pumpkin drop so what happens is this
building well let's see here's the
building and here's the here's the dot
that's the beautiful grass out on this
side of the building okay
and then there are some people up here
and very small objects well they're not
that small when you're close to them
they'd get dumped over the side there
and they they fall down that's you know
everything at MIT or a lot of things at
MIT or physics experiments so that's
that's the pumpkin drop so roughly
speaking actually this is the buildings
about 300 feet high we're we're down
here on the first useable floor and so
we're going to use instead of 300 feet
just for convenience purposes we'll use
80 meters because that makes the numbers
come out simply okay so so we have the
height which is starts out at 80 meters
at time 0 and then the acceleration due
to gravity gives you this formula for H
this is the height so at time T equals 0
we're up at the top H is 80 meters so
this is the met the unitive units here
are meters and at time T equals 4 you
notice five times 4 squared is 80 so I
picked these numbers conveniently so
that we're down at the bottom okay so so
this notion of average change here so
the average change or the average speed
here maybe we'll call it the average
speed since that's
over this time that it takes for the
pumpkin to drop is going to be the
change in H divided by the change in T
which is it starts out at what does it
start out as it starts out as a T right
and it ends at zero so actually we have
to do it backwards we have to take zero
minus 80 because the first value is the
final position and the second value is
the initial position and that's divided
by four minus zero time four seconds -
times zero seconds and so that of course
is the minus 20 meters per second so the
average speed of this guy is 20 meters a
second now so so why did I pick this
example because of course the average
its although interesting is not really
what anybody cares about who actually
goes to the event all we really care
about is the instantaneous speed when it
when it hits the pavement and so that's
can be calculated at the bottom so
what's the instantaneous me that's the
derivative or maybe I should to be
consistent with the notation I've been
using so far that's d by DT of H all
right so that's D by DT of H now
remember we have formulas for these
things we can differentiate this
function now we did that yesterday so
we're going to take the rate of change
and if you take a look at it it's just
the rate of change of a T is zero minus
the rate of change for this minus 5t
squared that's minus 10t alright so
that's using the fact that D by DT of a
T is equal to zero and D by DT
two squared is equal to 2t the special
case
well I'm cheating here but there's a
special case that's obvious I didn't
throw it in over here the case N equals
two is that second case there but the
case N equals zero also works right
because that's constants the derivative
of a constant is zero and then the
factor n there is zero and that's
consistent and actually if you look at
the formula above it you'll see that
it's the it's the case N equals minus 1
so we'll get a larger pattern soon
enough with the powers ok anyway back
over here we have our rate of change and
this is what it is and at the bottom at
the point of impact we have T is equal
to four and so H prime which is the
derivative is equal to minus 40 meters
per second so twice as fast as the
average speed here and if you need to
convert that that's about 90 miles an
hour which is why the police are there
at midnight on Halloween to make sure
you're all safe and also why when you
come you have to be prepared to clean up
afterwards so anyway that's what happens
it's 90 miles an hour it's actually the
building is a little taller but there's
air resistance and I'm sure you can do a
much more thorough study of this example
all right so now I want to give you a
couple of more examples because time is
and and and these kinds of parameters
and variables are not the only ones that
are important for calculus if it were
only this kind of physics that was
involved then this would be a much more
specialized subject than it is and so I
want to give you a couple of examples
that don't involve time as a variable so
the third example I'll give here is the
letter T often denotes temperature
and then D DT DX would be what is known
as the temperature gradient which we
really care about a lot when we're
predicting the weather because it's that
temperature difference that causes air
flows and it causes things to change and
then there's another theme which is
throughout the sciences and engineering
which I'm going to talk about under the
heading of sensitivity of measurements
so let me let me explain this I don't
want to be labor it because I just doing
this in order to introduce you to the
ideas on your problem set which are the
first case of this so on problem set one
you have an example which is based on a
simplified model of GPS sort of the Flat
Earth model and in that situation well
if the earth is flat it's just a
horizontal line like this and then you
have a satellite which is over here
preferably above the earth and the the
satellite is it knows exactly or the
system knows exactly where the point
directly below the satellite is so this
point is treated as known and I'm
sitting here ok with my little GPS
device and I want to know where I am and
the way I locate where I am is I
communicate with this satellite by radio
signals and I can measure this distance
here which is called H
and then the system will compute this
horizontal distance which is which is L
so in other words what's measured so H
measured by radios radio waves and a
clock or various clocks and then L is
deduced from from H and what's critical
in all of these systems is that you
don't know H exactly there's an error in
H which will denote Delta H there's some
degree of uncertainty the main
uncertainty in GPS is from the
ionosphere but there are lots of
Corrections that are made of all kinds
and also if you're inside a building
it's a problem to measure it but it's
it's an extremely important issue as
I'll explain in a second so the idea is
we we then get to the get at Delta L is
estimated by considering this ratio
Delta L over Delta H which is going to
be approximately the same as the
derivative of L with respect to H so
this is the thing that's easy because of
course it's calculus right calculus is
the easy part and that allows us to
deduce something about the real world
that's close by over here so the reason
why you should care about this quite a
bit is that it's it's used all the time
to land airplanes and so you really do
care that they actually know to within a
few feet or even closer where your plane
is and how high up it is and so forth
all right
so that's that's it for the general
introduction to what a derivative is I'm
sure you'll be getting used to this in a
lot of different contexts throughout the
course and now we have to get back down
to to some some rigorous details ok is
everybody happy with what we've got so
far
yeah ah good question the question was
how did I get this equation for height I
just made it up because it's the formula
from physics that you will learn when
you take 801 and it has to do with the
fact that the in fact it has to do with
the fact that if you this is speed if
you differentiate another time you get
acceleration and this is the
acceleration due to gravity is 10 meters
per second which happens to be the
second derivative of this but anyway I
just pulled it out of a hat from your
physics class so you can just say see
801 all right other questions all right
so let's let's go on now now I have to
be a little bit more systematic about
limits and so let's let's do that now
so now what I'd like to talk about is
limits and continuity and this is a
warm-up for deriving all the rest of the
formulas all the rest of the formulas
that I'm going to need to differentiate
every function you know remember that's
our goal and we only have about a week
left so we'd better get started so first
of all there's what I will call easy
limits so what's an easy limit an easy
limit is something like the limit as X
goes to 4 of X plus 3 over x squared
plus 1 and with this kind of limit all I
have to do to evaluate it is to plug in
x equals 4 because so so what I get here
is 4 plus 3 divided by 4 squared plus
one and that's just 7 divided by 17 and
that's the end of it so those are the
easy limits the second kind of limit
well so this isn't the only second kind
of limit but I just want to point this
out it's very important is that
derivatives are always harder than this
you can't get away with nothing here so
why is that well when you take a
derivative you're taking the limit as X
goes to X 0 of f of X well f of X let's
try we'll write it all out in all its
glory
here's the the formula for a derivative
now notice that if you plug in x equals
x zero always gives zero over zero so it
just basically never works so we always
are going to need some cancellation to
make sense out of the limit now in order
to in order to make things a little
easier for myself to explain what's
going on with limits I need to introduce
just one more piece of notation what I'm
going to introduce here is what's known
as a left hand and a right hand limit if
I take the limit as X tends to X 0 with
a plus sign here of some function this
is what's known as the right hand limit
and I can display it visually so what
does this mean it means practically the
same thing as X tends to X 0 except
there's one more restriction which has
to do with this plus sign which is we're
going from the plus side of X 0 that
means X is bigger than X 0 and I say
right hand so there should be a hyphen
here by hand limit because on the number
line if X 0 is over here the X is
whoops sorry the X is to the right
alright so that's a right hand limit and
then this being the left side of the
board I'll put on the right side of the
board the left limit just to make things
confusing so that one has the minus sign
here
I'm just a little dyslexic and I hope
you're not so I may have gotten that
wrong but so this is the left hand limit
and I'll draw it so of course that just
means X goes to X 0 but X is to the left
of X 0 and again on the number line
here's the X 0 and the X is on the other
side of it okay so those two notations
are going to help us to clarify a bunch
of things it's much more convenient to
have this extra bit of description of
limits than to just consider limits from
both sides ok so I want to give an
example of this and also an example of
how you're going to think about these
sorts of problems so I'll take a
function which has two different
definitions say it's X plus 1 when X is
bigger than 0 and minus X plus 2 when X
is less than 0 all right so maybe put
commas there those are so when X is
greater than 0 it's it's X plus 1 now I
can draw a picture of this it's going to
be kind of a little small because I'm
going to try to fit it down in here but
maybe I'll put the axis down below so so
at height 1 I have to the right I have
something of slope 1 so it goes up like
this all right and then to the left of 0
I have something which has slope
negative 1 but it hits the axis at 2 so
it's up here all right so I have this
sort of strange antenna figure here
which is my graph maybe I could should
draw these in another color to depict
that all right
and then if I calculate these two limits
here what I see is that the limit as X
goes to 0 from above of f of X that's
the same as the limit as X goes to 0 of
the formula here X plus 1 which turns
out to be 1 and if I take the limit from
the so that's the left-hand limit that's
this sorry that's sorry though yeah I
told you I was dyslexic which right this
is the right so it's that that right
half here we go so now I'm going from
the left and it's f of X again but now
because I'm on that side the thing I
need to plug in is the other formula
minus X plus 2 and that's going to give
us 2 now notice that the left and right
limits and this is one little tiny
subtlety and it's almost the only thing
that I need you to really pay attention
to a little bit right now is that this
we did not need need x equals 0 value in
fact I never even told you what f of 0
was here if we stick it in we could
stick it in ok let's say we stick it in
on on this side let's let's make it be
that it's on this side so that means
that this point is in and this point is
out so that's a typical notation this
little open circle and this closed dot
for when you include the so so in that
case the value of f of X happens to be
the same as its right hand limit namely
the value is 1 here and not 2
okay so that's the the the first kind of
example question okay so now our next
job is to introduce the definition of
continuity so that was the other topic
here so we're going to define so F is
continuous at X 0 means that the limit
of f of X as X tends to X 0 is equal to
f of X 0 right so so the reason why I
spent all this time paying attention to
the left and the right and so on and so
forth and focusing is that I I want you
to pay attention for one moment to what
the content of this of this definition
is what it's saying is the following so
a continuous at X 0 has has a various
ingredients here so the first one is
that this limit exists and what that
means is that there's an honest limiting
value both from the left and right and
they also have to be the same all right
so that's that's what's going on here
and the second property is that f of X 0
is defined so I can't be in one of these
situations where I haven't even
specified what f of X 0 is and they're
equal
okay so that's the situation now again
let me emphasize a tricky part of the
definition of a limit this side the
left-hand side is completely independent
is evaluated by a procedure which does
not involve the right-hand side these
are separate things this one is to
evaluate it you always avoid the limit
point so that's if you like a paradox
because it's exactly the question is is
it true that if you plug in X 0 you get
the same answer as if you move in the
limit that's the issue that we're
considering here we have to make that
distinction in order to say that these
are two the other otherwise this is just
tautological it makes it's a very little
it doesn't have any meaning but in fact
it does have a meaning because one thing
is evaluated separately with reference
to all the other points and the other is
evaluated right at the point in question
and indeed what these things are are
exactly the easy limits that's exactly
what we're talking about here they're
the ones that you can evaluate this way
so we have to make the distinction and
these other ones are going to be the
ones which we can't evaluate that way so
these are the nice ones and that's why
we care about them why we have a whole
definition associated with them all
right so now so now what's next well I
need to give you a little tour a very
brief tour of the zoo of what are known
as discontinuous functions so sort of
everything else that's not continuous so
the first example here let me just write
it down here is jump discontinuities
so what would a jump discontinuity be
well we've actually already seen it the
jump discontinuity is the example that
we had right there this is when the
limit from the left left and right
exists but are not equal okay so that's
that's the as in the example right in
this example the two limits one of them
was one and one of them was two so
that's a jump discontinuity and this
kind of issue of whether something is
continuous or not is may seem a little
bit technical but but it is true that
that that people have worried about it a
lot the Bob Merton who was a professor
at MIT when he did his work for the
Nobel Prize in Economics was interested
in this very issue of whether stock
prices of various kinds are continuous
from the left or right in a certain
model and that was a very serious issue
in developing the model that that priced
things that are hedge funds use all the
time now so left and right really can
mean something very different in this
case left is the past
and right is the future and it makes a
big difference whether things are
continuous from the left or continues
from the right right is it true that the
point is here here somewhere in the
middle somewhere else that's a serious
issue so the next example that I want to
give you is a little bit more subtle
it's what's known as a removable
discontinuity and so what this means is
that the limit from left and right are
equal so a picture of that would be you
have a function which is coming along
like this and there's a hole maybe where
who knows either the function is
undefined or maybe it's defined up here
and then it just continues on alright so
that the two limits are the same and
then of course the function is begging
to be redefined so that we remove that
hole and that's why it's called a
removable discontinuity now let me give
you an example of this are actually a
couple of examples so these are quite
important examples which we'll be
working with in just a few in it in a
few minutes so so the first is the
function G of X which is sine x over X
and the second will be the function H of
X which is 1 minus cosine X over X so we
have a problem at G of 0 G of 0 is
undefined on the other hand it turns out
that this function has what's called a
removable singularity namely the limit
as X goes to 0 of sine x over X does
exist in fact it's equal to 1 so that's
a very important limit that will work
out either at the end of this lecture or
the beginning of next lecture and
similarly the limit of 1 minus cosine X
divided by X
X goes to zero is zero maybe I'll put
that a little farther away so you can
read it okay so these are these are very
useful facts that we're going to need
later on and what they say is that these
things have removable singularities
sorry removable discontinuity at x
equals zero
all right so as I say well we'll get to
that in a in a in a few minutes okay so
are there any questions before I move on
yet
the question is why is this true
is that is that what your question is
the answer is it's very very unobvious I
haven't shown it to you yet and there's
if you were not surprised by it then
that would be very strange indeed so we
haven't done it yet you have to stay
tuned until we do okay we haven't shown
it yet and actually even this other
statement which maybe seems stranger
still is also not yet explained okay so
we are going to get there as I said
either at the end of this lecture or at
the beginning of next other questions
all right so let me let me just continue
my tour of the zoo of discontinuities
and I guess I want to illustrate
something with the convenience of right
and left hand limits so I'll save this
board about right and left hand limits
so a third type of discontinuity is
what's known as an infinite
discontinuity and we've already
encountered one of these I'm going to
draw them over here remember the
function y is 1 over X that's this
function here but now I'd like to draw
also the other branch of the per app of
the hyperbola down here and allow myself
to consider negative values of X so
here's the graph of 1 over X and the
convenience here of the distinguishing
left on the right hand limits is very
important because here I can write down
that the limit as X goes to 0 plus of 1
over X well that's coming from the right
and it's going up so this limit is
infinity whereas the limit in the other
direction from the left that one is
going down and so it's quite different
it's minus infinity now some people say
that these limits are undefined but
actually they're going into some very
definite directions so you should you
should whenever possible specify what
these limits are on the other hand the
statement that the limit as X goes to 0
of 1 over X is infinity is is simply
wrong ok
it's not that people don't write this
it's just that it's wrong it's not that
they don't write it down I mean in fact
you'll probably see it and it's because
people are just thinking of the of the
right hand branch it's not that they're
making a mistake not because necessarily
but anyway it's sloppy and there's some
sloppiness that will endure and others
that will try to avoid so here you want
to say this and it does make a
difference you know plus infinity is a
you know an infinite number of dollars
and minus and
infinity is an infinite amount of debt
they're actually different they're not
the same so you know this is sloppy and
this is actually more correct okay so
now in addition I just want to point out
one more thing remember we calculated
the derivative and that was minus 1 over
x squared but I want to so I want to
draw the graph of that and make a few
comments about it so I'm going to draw
the graph directly underneath the the
graph of the function and notice what
this graph is it goes like this
it's always negative and it points down
so now this may look a little strange
that the derivative of this thing is
this guy but that's because of something
very important and you should always
remember this about derivatives the
derivative of function looks nothing
like the function necessarily so you
should just forget about that as being
an idea some people feel like if one
thing goes down that other thing has to
go down just forget that intuition it's
wrong what we're dealing with here if
you remember is the slope so if you have
a slope here that's corresponds to just
a place over here and there's a slope
gets a little bit less steep that's why
we're approaching the the horizontal
axis we're getting a little the numbers
getting a little smaller as we close in
now over here this slope is also
negative it's going down and as we get
down here it's getting more and more
negative as we go here the slope this
function is going up but its slope is
going down alright so the slope is down
on both sides and the notation that we
use for that is well suited to this to
this left and right business
namely the limit as X goes to 0 of
negative 1 over x squared that's going
to be equal to minus infinity and that
applies to X going to 0 plus and X going
to 0 minus so so both add this property
in it finally let me just make one last
comment about these two graphs this
function here is an odd function and
when you take the derivative of an odd
function you always get an even function
and that's closely related to the fact
that this 1 over X is an odd power in
this to X to the first power is an odd
power and x squared is an even power so
all of the your intuition should be
reinforcing the fact that these pictures
look right ok now there's one last kind
of discontinuity that I want to mention
briefly which I will call other ugly
discontinuities and there are lots and
lots of them and so one example would be
the function y is equal to sine 1 over X
as X goes to 0 and that looks a little
bit like this
back and forth and back and forth it
oscillates infinitely often as we tend
to zero and there's there's no left or
right limit in this case so there is a
very large quantity of things like that
fortunately we're not going to deal with
them in this in this course a lot of
times in real life there are things that
oscillate as time goes to infinity but
but we're not going to worry about that
right now okay so that's our final
mention of a discontinuity and and now I
need to do just one more piece of
groundwork for our formulas next time
namely I want to check for you one basic
fat one limiting tool so this is going
to be a theorem but fortunately it's a
very short theorem and has a very short
proof so the theorem goes under the name
differentiable implies continuous and
what it says is the following it says
that if F is differentiable in other
words it's a derivative exists at X 0
then F is continuous
at x0 so we're going to need this as a
tool a key step in the product and
quotient rules so I'd like to prove it
right now for you so here's the proof
fortunately the proof Asst is just one
line so first of all I want to write in
just the right way what it is that we
have to check so what we have to check
is that the limit as X goes to X 0 of f
of X minus f of X 0 is equal to 0 so
this is what we want to know we don't
know it yet but we're trying to check
whether this is true or not so that's
the same as the statement that the
function is continuous because the limit
of f of X is supposed to be f of X 0 and
so this difference should have limits 0
and now the way this is proved is just
by rewriting it by multiplying and
dividing by X minus x0 so I'll rewrite
the limit as X goes to X 0 of f of X
minus f of X 0 divided by X minus x0
times X minus x0 ok so I wrote down the
same expression that I had here this is
just the same limit but I multiplied and
divided by X minus x0
and now when I take the limit what
happens is the limit of the first factor
is f prime of X zero that's the thing we
know exists by our assumption and the
limit of the second factor is zero
because the limit is X goes X 0 of X
minus x0 is clearly zero so that's it
the answer is zero which is what we
wanted all right so that's that's the
proof now there's something exceedingly
fishy looking about this proof and let
me just point to it before we proceed
namely you're used in limits to setting
X equal to zero and this looks like
we're multiplying dividing by zero
exactly the thing which makes all proofs
wrong in all kinds of algebraic
situations and so on and so forth you've
been taught that that never works right
but somehow these limiting tricks have
found a way around this and let me just
make explicit what it is in this limit
we never are using x equals x 0 that's
exactly the 1 value of x that we don't
consider in this limit that's how limits
are cooked up and that's sort of been
the theme so far today is that we don't
have to consider that and so this
multiplication and division by this
number is legal
it may be small this number but it's
always nonzero and so this really works
and it's really true and we've just
checked that a differentiable function
is continuous so I'm going to have to do
these carry out these limits which are
very interesting zero over zero zero
limits next time but let's hang on for
one second to see if there any questions
before we stop yeah there is a question
I'll repeat this this proof right here
okay just say it say again okay so there
are two steps to the proof and the croup
the step that you're asking about is the
first step
right and what I'm saying is if you have
a number and you multiply it by 10 over
10 it's the same number if you multiply
it by 3 over 3 it's the same number 2
over 2 1 over 1 and so on so so it's
okay to change this to this it's exactly
the same thing that's that's the first
step yes the question was how does the
proof how does this line yeah where the
question mark is so what I checked was
that this number which is on the left
hand side is equal to this note this
very long complicated number which is
equal to this number which is equal to
this number and so I've checked that
this number is equal to 0 because the
last thing is 0 this is equal to that is
equal to that is equal to 0 and that's
that's the proof yes
yeah so you're that's it that's a
different question okay so the the
hypothesis of differentiability I use
because this limit is equal to this
number that that limit exists that's how
I use the hypothesis of the theorem the
conclusion of the theorem is the same as
this because being continuous is the
same as limit as X goes to X zero of f
of X is equal to f of X zero that's the
definition of continuity and I
subtracted f of X zero from both sides
to get this as being the same thing so
this claim is continuity and it's the
same as this this question here this
issue here last question
how do we get the zero from this so the
claim that's being made so the claim is
why is this tending to that so for
example I'm going to have to erase
something to explain that so the claim
is that the limit as X goes to X 0 of X
minus X 0 is equal to 0 that's that's
what I'm claiming ok does that answer
your question
ok all right ask me else other stuff
after lecture